if I was in charge over MGM and Amazon
this is what I would do with the
Stargate franchise and some of you are
going to absolutely hate my ideas
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so if I was in charge this is how I
would start the Stargate franchise I
would start it first of all with an
animated movie and I can almost hear
many of you go in
you idiot
but an animated movie to conclude
Stargate Universe now I have my reasons
why I think it should be an animated
movie I think
Stargate Universe is a little bit
divisive now people either love it or
not so much I'm in the founded a little
bit boring camp but I would love to
still see a conclusion I still want to
see Eli come home I still want to see
Russian Telford and everybody come home
so I think an animated movie is the way
to go I think for several reasons I
don't think it's actually as popular as
sg1 and SGA I think that from a
financial point of view again if I was
in charge at MJ and Amazon I'm not sure
I'd want to put as much money into this
as a live-action movie or miniseries or
series would actually cost
um rebuilding all the sets getting the
actors
um like Robert Carlisle on long-term
deals again all of this would be very
expensive
an animated movie though not so much
um you could get people in to do the
voices it wouldn't cost a great deal of
money obviously then you haven't got
sets Etc to build but also you could
produce this very quickly
Stargate Universe the movie could be on
our screens within say eight or nine
months and I actually think it would be
really really popular and a very
interesting way to kick off the new
franchise you get to close the loop on
Stargate Universe and the old franchise
and actually do something that then sets
up where you're going next
following the SGU animated movie I can
still hear people actually going oh God
no please no but you know that's just
because I know you guys so well so get
into the comments tell me how much you
hate that idea
um or if you love the idea get in the
comments as well
next though I would actually do a series
potentially actually I might do a mini
series I'm actually thinking what sort
of Battle Star Galactica did say a three
or four hour movie quality project
something really big really ambitious
but set up as a mini series on Amazon I
would put this on Amazon Prime I would
get as many people to see it as humanly
possible and I would do it as a
bridging project something that will
really tell us what's happened in the
last 15 years in the Stargate Universe
something that would then set up the
Cinematic movie that we believe is
coming
it would be a big advert for the movie
but I want it to be ambitious
I do think a 10 episode series is also a
possibility for this but a mini series
might have a little bit more impact
something that can give us a foundation
for the new franchise something that we
can then jump off from something that
actually answers a lot of the questions
we've got for the what's happened in the
last 15 years but also asks new
questions
introduce a bunch of new characters as
well as telling us where a bunch of the
characters we already love are and what
they're doing
I just think we need a series of
something before a movie a movie needs
something before it it needs something
that's going to set it up it needs
something to answer all those questions
a two-hour movie can't do that and I do
think the movie
doesn't need that pressure doesn't need
a director or a writer trying to
shoehorn in all this information a movie
needs to just be a movie it needs to be
fun it needs to be action-packed it
needs to tell a story that excites us
but it doesn't need to spend the time
answering questions the series could
but then after the miniseries or little
series whatever I do want a cinematic
movie I do think
the franchise deserves the big impact of
a cinematic movie I love the idea to be
honest if it went straight to streaming
either I wouldn't mind but a movie I
actually think what we've seen in the
last couple of years that actually the
films that go straight to streaming in
2023 have been better than a lot of the
films that have gone to cinema I like
the idea that the franchise gets a movie
something that Star Trek isn't getting I
like the idea that it would bring a lot
of good positive attention to the
franchise and I just like the idea that
actually Amazon would do that to show
that it really is putting everything
behind the Stargate franchise like I
hope they're going to do because Amazon
do have the ability to make Stargate
into a really a franchise that does
challenge
what I would argue a slightly Wandering
Star Trek franchise Star Trek at the
moment to me has cracks there are
massive problems there
and Stargate could come into this
really fresh in lots of ways and without
a lot of the problems that Star Trek is
trying to fix and nothing says we're
serious more than a cinematic movie
following the movie though we need a
proper series we need two or three
proper series maybe telling slightly
different stories I've talked about the
Marvel model that Amazon had started
thinking about over a year ago having
movies TV series maybe animated projects
Etc that all influence each other that
all existed in the same universe I
actually think that is the way to go I
want to see a Jaffa series I want to see
an ancient prequel series I want to see
a Stargate more sg1 style series
something more traditionally Stargate
I'd love to see all of these things
running at the same time now I've spoken
to sources over at Amazon and MGM and
they're telling me that does seem to be
the idea that the sort of working plan
at the moment is that Amazon will get
two or three sound stages and that they
will be the Stargate Studios that they
will be running everything Stargate out
of those two or three places and all of
these projects will be running at the
same time that would be efficient it
would be cost effective and it would
give us lots and lots of Stargate now I
know there's a bit of a fatigue of Star
Trek Star Wars Etc but Stargate is
almost unique in the way that it's got
such a vast Universe with so many
different aspects to it and a history a
Canon that's not been confused like Star
Trek's has but then what would I do what
would be the Wild Card what would be the
project that will really annoy many of
you
I do and I'm serious about this I would
do a wormhole extreme cartoon series I
would do it like sort of how they've
done lower decks I would do it as a
grown-up cartoon don't do a kids cartoon
to be honest kids don't watch cartoons
anymore and the quicker that people like
the guys that did Prodigy realize that
the better kids watch YouTube
they just don't watch cartoons not
anything like what they used to the
whole thing of Saturday morning cartoons
is dead it's gone it's the 90s
don't do a kid's cartoon do a grown-up
animated cartoon something a bit like
lower decks with some humor outside of
the Universe I think the mistake lower
Dex makes is that it's in Canon but it's
not
I think you do Wormhole extreme
something that is
a different universe but still Stargate
that you can sort of take the Mickey and
point fun and make fun out of Stargate
and you can actually you know have a
little bit of influence you know stories
that actually sort of maybe tell some of
the original Star game stores from a
different perspective I just think that
if you have somebody that really loves
Stargate and you give them a completely
blank canvas of Wormhole extreme where
they can say look you can mess around
with Canon you can tell the stories that
we've already seen from different
perspectives you can do lots and lots of
things you can really do whatever you
want and have fun with it they could
create something that's really
interesting
lots of fun and you know that would
tickle our silly bones a little bit and
that you know actually add something to
the bigger franchise while adding a bit
of fun
I just think it's a really interesting
idea that I know will annoy many of you
so that is my idea for the Stargate
franchise
animated SGU movie short series that
sets up the new franchise cinematic
movie a proper full-on series and if all
successful wormall extreme comedy
animated series
what do you think you'd like to see
though what out of my plan do you like
what my plan do you hate I think I'm
going to get a few more hate than like
but it's my plan sir
I'd love to know though what you think
so get to the comments if you're new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification there's links in
the description and you can see all of
these going across the bottom please as
always stay safe and I'll see you next
time
good foreign
foreign
[Music]